j'aurais juste comme on a Daniel ici je
voudrais juste que Daniel euh si vous
voulez comme vous voulez vous pouvez
réagir ou pas parce que on avait euh
Omar Sy qui a fait énormément parler lui
aujourd'hui
Omar Sy depuis ce matin il fait beaucoup
parler de lui sur les réseaux sociaux il
semblerait que les propos qu'il a tenu
lors d'une interview accordée au
Parisien n'est pas plus à tout le monde
l'acteur s'est exprimé sur le soutien
des Français aux Ukrainiens dans leur
conflits avec la Russie en estimant ils
se sont moins atteint lorsqu'il s'agit
de guerre en Afrique et c'est vrai que
ça a été repris partout voilà ce qui a
dit ce qui a dit Omar Sy et c'est vrai
qu'il s'est fait défoncer aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez je trouvais
que c'est un totalement d'accord avec
Omar Sy c'est vrai que on s'intéresse à
ce qui se passe en Ukraine on nous dit
c'est parce que c'est en Europe ce qui
se passe mais il y a 58 militaires
français qui sont morts au Mali par
exemple oui donc
il dit qu'il y a une émotion
considérable des Français pour ce qui se
passe en Ukraine et que parallèlement ce
qui concerne l'Afrique moi je vais dire
l'histoire c'est juste que c'est et
c'est ça qui est grave je suis d'accord
avec lui là dessus c'est que c'est moins
médiatisé
les Français tu mets pas les Français
dans la sauce c'est juste que c'est moi
médiatisé comme par le moins les
Français forcément il y a moins
d'émotions mais c'est les journalistes
et les médias qui font qu'on parle moins
et c'est s'il avait dit les journalistes
font qu'aujourd'hui il y a moins il y a
il y a il y a il y a moins de prise de
conscience par rapport à ce qui se passe
en Afrique quand tu craignes moi je vous
dis les seuls responsables sont les
journalistes ce ne sont pas les français
donc les Français les pauvres oui on
leur parle plus du crâne toute la
journée il voit des images terribles en
Ukraine donc forcément ils se sont
impliqués dans la guerre en Ukraine
j'aimerais qu'on monte plus c'est aussi
l'image moi de ce qui se passe en
Afrique dans les journaux c'est la
Russie aujourd'hui en France dans les
journaux télévisés bien sûr voilà et je
suis d'accord plutôt que et donc là les
Français aussi serait beaucoup plus
concernés parce que tu en penses
exactement c'est exactement le problème
des chaînes info et c'est un info
centralisée sur l'Ukraine on parle que
de l'Ukraine et puis on oublie tout ce
qui se passe les massacres qui se
passent en Afrique au Soudan tout ce qui
arrive enfin c'est après monstrueuse qui
arrive on en parle jamais il s'est fait
il s'est fait défoncer alors qu'est-ce
que alors d'abord je trouve très très
bien qu'il fasse un film là-dessus sur
l'intérieur parce que on connaît pas
l'histoire sauf que qui fasse un truc
dessus qui en plus peut-être ne marchera
pas sera pas un blockmaster donc c'est
formidable qui le fasse en revanche pour
moi c'est un dérapage parce qu'il nous
culpabilise mais pardon il y a un moment
on est des êtres humains on a tous nos
emmerde toute la journée payer son gaz
vivre et tout ça alors l'Ukraine on en a
parlé parce que ça nous impacte
directement et je reconnais
qu'effectivement ce qui se passe souvent
au Mali ou en Afrique comme il y a moins
d'intérêt économique
ça nous touche moi c'est comme ça nous
touche moi on peut pas être touché c'est
très gratte les guerres du monde et par
tous les c'est très grave mais nous dire
qu'on est pas touché par l'Afrique et
qu'on est touché par l'Ukraine bah oui
parce que l'Ukraine ça rentre dans
l'ordinateur je suis touché par ce qui
se passe bien sûr
tu peux pas choisir tes indignations tu
peux pas choisir non je dis que ça n'a
pas la vie des Français comprend ça les
migrants les pauvres
tu peux me citer un conflit en ce moment
en Afrique qui te touche vraiment
beaucoup voilà tiens grande gueule je
m'intéresse à l'Afrique est-ce que tu
commences
si tu es un pays qui est en train
d'attaquer votre pays ce qui se passe au
Congo les rébellions qui sont au Kenya
les rébellions qui sont en Éthiopie moi
ça m'intéresse particulièrement les
familles il y a des famines terribles
non mais ça c'est pas assez depuis
toujours d'accord mais il paraît
d'accord d'un conflit d'un conflit les
migrants les migrants qui sont obligés
de fumer pour des raisons économiques
beaucoup moins excusez-moi mais on en
parle beaucoup moins le moins africains
qui traîne pardon
les gens en France Cyril les gens en
France il paye le gaz il y a plus
d'essence il y a plus rien ça impacte
leur vie c'est très triste qui se passe
en Afrique évidemment que c'est triste
mais bien sûr pas trop de Reda qu'est-ce
que tu le ferais ce concours tu as été
dans une rédaction toi tu sais très bien
comment ça marche les rédactions est-ce
qu'on fait un concours le matin est-ce
que c'est pas plus parler de ça que de
ça que ça alors juste est-ce que c'est
pas est-ce qu'il a pas voulu faire une
réaction
envers le gouvernement qui a plus
l'Ukraine l'Afrique c'est ça oui moi je
pense qu'il a raison je pense qu'il y a
une forme il y a une forme d'hypocrisie
autour dedans en Afrique
il y a une forme d'hypocrisie autour de
cette guerre qui est qui le portable il
y a plein de conflits dont personne ne
parle dans d'autres pays et Mathieu tu
parles des conséquences mais cet élève
avant les conséquences les médias en ont
tout de suite beaucoup parlé et voilà et
je trouve que les gens ont tendance à
suivre un peu bêtement comme des moutons
sur certaines personnes ce que disent
tous les médias est-ce que leur impose
les médias et effectivement on ne parle
que de la guerre en Ukraine sur les
chaînes info et on ne parle pas d'autres
conflits qui dure depuis longtemps
j'ai perdu
les chéris juste nous non c'est comme
ici on nous reprocher un moment de
parler de deux Zemmour c'est où on en
parlait partout c'est lui qui faisait le
buzz tous les jours il sortait une
phrase donc forcément on en parlait ici
tous les jours et c'est vrai que à un
moment tu es sur l'actualité forcément
voilà après c'est vrai que il parle pas
beaucoup aussi des des autres conflits
j'attends ce que tu dis mais la plupart
des Français c'est qu'est-ce que j'ai
bouffer demain alors je reconnais
effectivement on peut pas leur en
vouloir de savoir ce qui se passe au
Mali au Rwanda au machin c'est un peu
compliqué mais ça va pas c'est pas leur
quotidien tu vois ce que je veux dire
l'Ukraine ça va m'intéresse de revenir à
Homar sy parce que il s'est fait
défoncer ouais toute la journée
aujourd'hui il est en TT il en a pris
plein la gueule voilà pas Nathalie
Loiseau il y a 58 militaires français
qui sont morts au Sahel en luttant
contre des djihadistes non merci les
Français ne sont pas moins atteints
parce qu'ils se passe en Afrique
certains ont donné leur vie pour que les
Maliens cessent d'être menacés par des
terroristes il y en a plein qui ont
reproché aussi de vivre aux États-Unis
est-ce que qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
vous qui remontent je pense comme toi je
pense que c'est vrai qu'il aurait dû
s'attaquer d'abord aux médias et aux
journalistes pas aux Français parce que
nous mine de rien on suit le mouvement
on nous dit l'Ukraine on a des intérêts
bah franchement la guerre à l'Ukraine et
ben allons-y on fait la guerre à la gare
du crâne mais moi je suis un enfant des
enfants d'Éthiopie il y a toujours une
non mais non mais non je reste au marché
ce qu'on est choqué parce que moi je
suis choqué parce qu'il prend en otage
c'est pas du tout et certains vont dire
et toi tu es aux États-Unis tu es même
pas ici mais quelque part je le
comprends quelque part je le comprends
parce que quand on envoie des militaires
en Afrique au Mali comme vous dites
c'est où parce qu'on a des intérêts
parce qu'il y a du pétrole parce qu'il y
a total ou parce qu'il y a de l'uranium
mais sinon l'Éthiopie à crève de faim
depuis 40 ans on en a rien à il y
a plein de pays en Afrique ils crèvent
de fin on en a rien à parce qu'on
peut pas aider la terre entière et là
l'Ukraine par contre à tout prix les
boulangers l'essence à tout prix faut
aller des Ukraine c'est peut-être
l'Afrique l'Afrique on en a tous rien à
fumer
la chanson
moi je trouve qu'il a un petit côté oui
oui qui fait de la géopolitique c'est
plein de bonnes intentions je suis un
peu d'accord il mélange tout et même il
met sur le même niveau l'Ukraine et
l'Iran alors qu'il y a un pays comme
l'Ukraine qui se fait attaquer par la
Russie la Russie aujourd'hui celle qui
est avec les ministre Wagner partout en
Afrique donc il ferait mieux de
s'occuper plutôt des mix Wagner que nous
parce que nous on a été dégagé du Mali
donc c'est beaucoup plus compliqué que
ça la géopolitique et je trouve que Omar
Sy c'est mieux qu'il parle de cinéma et
pas géopolitique parce que là je le
trouve totalement largué moi juste moi
je vous dis moi je pense que ce qu'a
voulu dire oh merci et je suis bien je
viens en aide moi je pense qu'il a voulu
dire que et je suis d'accord avec lui
c'est que les médias devraient parler
aussi d'autres conflits je suis désolé
et c'est vrai que il n'en parle pas et
il y a énormément je vous dis
d'Africains qui viennent voir moi dans
la rue et qui me disent c'est vrai que
Cyril on parle pas de si on parle pas de
ça il y a plein de migrants à Paris à
côté de chez moi
je pense pas qu'il a pas il est pas
envie qu'on aide le crâne mais il
aimerait qu'on est tout le monde et
voilà on essaie et c'est ça voilà c'est
c'est un peu de voilà de de faire un
petit peu le le cas du diable tu as
raison il culpabilité
oui voilà souvenez vous tes Provost oui
à 47% de nous à 52%